- [Voiceover] Owls have
a very robust diet.
In fact, larger species
of owls are known to eat
skunks, rabbits, and even porcupines.
So this was written in a very,
or the punctuation here
seems very strange.
Especially this semicolon
right over here seems wrong.
And then even putting the
comma after the "and" there.
So let's look at the other options.
So I definitely want to change this.
So here, owls are known to eat
skunks, comma, rabbits,
comma, so far so good.
And, and then they put another comma.
Well, this seems off.
So because of that I'm gonna rule it out.
Or it doesn't seem off, it is off.
You wouldn't put the comma after the and.
So here, skunks, comma,
rabbits, semi-colon.
Well, I didn't like that from the get-go.
Skunks, comma, rabbits, comma, and even.
Yep, that's right.
You put a comma after each
listing you're listing
until you get to the and,
and then you just list the last thing.
This is the one that is correct.